明明判断对了方向
行情也确实涨了
设置你提前画好了趋势线
均线逻辑清晰
一切看上去都对
但等你实际下场交易
结果却是被洗出来
追进去止损再追再止损
一波趋势走下来
你的账户禁止甚至比原地踏步还惨
这不是你一个人的问题
而是大多数交易者共同的困境
趋势判断没错
执行却全错
而且更棘手的是
这种错误不会暴露在图表里
不会暴露在逻辑里
它暴露在实盘的行为细节里
你明明看对了
却完全做不对
这不是偶发
而是结构性问题
所以我们先别急着谈怎么交易趋势
第一步要问的其实是趋势到底难不难判断
很多人以为自己交易做不好
是因为不会判断趋势
但真相可能正好相反
趋势方向其实大多数时候非常清楚
只要你在图上加上一根EMA50均线
大多数行情的多空结构一目了然
价格在均线之上并持续抬升
就是多头
价格在均线之下并不断下破
就是空头趋势并没有你想象中那么玄乎
它不是靠盘感抓出来的
是图上写的清清楚楚
问题从来不在于你看不懂
而在于你不信你看到的东西
你总想多看一眼
等个完美机会再确认一次趋势是否真的成立
结果就是你总在趋势走完之后才肯动手
或者刚动手就没动
你要被洗掉
说白了你把趋势判断当成了交易的终点
实际上它只是一个大致方向的起点
那为什么明明方向这么清楚
磁盘结果却这么难看
问题就出在下一层
你根本没有一整套可以执行的行为系统
要在趋势中赚钱
你就必须接受一件事
没人能抄到最低点
你只能通过多次试错
小仓测试逐步介入到趋势中
这意味着你要经历一些失败
比如保本离场
回归出场
反复试探
这些过程是趋势交易的必经之路
但大多数人没有建立明确的规则
来应对这一过程
什么时候是试错几次就该放弃
什么条件算真正启动
该不该补仓
这些问题没有答案的时候
你的操作就只能靠感觉
而感觉在实盘中非常不可靠
更严重的是
你很容易把趋势交易幻想成一次完美压住
一次进场去抓住整段趋势
只要现实不配合
你就开始动摇
开始怀疑趋势是否真的存在
更糟糕的是
即便趋势真的起来了
很多人也已经彻底被情绪反噬
就算趋势启动了
问题还没完
你可能因为前面事做太多
早早离场
或者因为怕高位被套
一直等回调
可真正回调了
你又不敢买
看着价格飞起来
你开始心态失衡了
早知道我就不止损了
等它跌回起点
我一定重仓买入
结果是什么
不是追涨被套
就是错过之后反手空一次比一次离谱
很多交易者不是死在技术上
而是死在错过之后的情绪包袱上
趋势不是让你精准抓起点
而是让你在合理结构中找切入
但如果你扛不住踏空
这整套情绪反扑
你就很难在趋势里拿住拿酒
更谈不上盈利
No
所以如果你真的想把趋势交易做好
最需要建立的其实不是判断力
而是你没有办法把方向感
变成一套具体的操作流程
每次行情来临时
你知道该怎么判断
怎么下手
怎么控制风险
其实交易听起来是个很大的理念
但归根结底它只是一个可执行的流程框架
真正落实到操作就是三件事
确认方向确认结构确认时机
结构确认是第一道关口
我的原则是
只要价格站在核心均线上方才考虑做多
并且前提是价格不能刚刚大幅上涨到前高附近
而是出现了健康回踩
这两者必须同时满足
否则不是追高就是搏反弹
参与价值都不大
方向轻主结构没坏
但市场的短期情绪如果还没释放
那进场后大概率会陷入震荡或二次杀跌
这时候我会用波段过滤器
识别这波回调到底属于哪一类
如果它是趋势中的初级超卖
那就意味着市场给出的切入信号
反之节奏没乱不动
直到这里
你只是有条件可以做
但真要放大仓位
必须等信号重合
我的做法是
只有当结构和情绪两者同时达标
才把这笔交易立为主力计划
方向未变
结构健康
情绪超卖
这是我对可以中餐交易的基本定义
除此之外的信号
即便胜率不低
也只属于是探单小伤跟随不承担主观预期
所以说白了你是给自己制定一个什么时候动
什么时候不动的明确流程
让每一笔操作都有依据
而不是情绪反应
如果你把今天讲的这套系统反复去想
就会发现
其实我们一直在解决一个核心问题
不是你不会看趋势
不是你判断不准
而是你没有能力把判断转换成操作
你说看涨
但进场早晚全靠感觉
你说顺势
但仓位大小随情绪起伏
你说系统可真正走进市场时
一切逻辑全被打乱
最终你不是输给市场
而是一次次被自己的交易习惯反噬
市场不会逼你亏钱
它只是放大了你原本没有解决的问题
所以你不是缺少判断力
而是缺少管理自己的行为机制
当你构建出那个该动时动
不该动就停的闭环结构
交易才会从失控变成节奏
从混乱变成计划
别再把问题怪在行情太快
活动太急
假突破太多
真正的问题是你还没练出
让自己稳定盈利的执行模式